いや本当にバウンティーハンターしちゃったｗｗ
こんにちは
いや…こんばんはというべきか…
はじめしゃちょーと
クッフッフッフッフッｗｗｗｗ
その毎回照れるのなんなのw
まさやです
っふふw
は：久しぶりですね　ま：久しぶりですねこの企画
まぁだいぶ熱くなってきたのでそろそろいってもいいのではないのということで
今回も～静岡県の心霊スポット
巡っていきたいと思います。
浜松市っていう愛知県と静岡県の間ぐらいの場所に来ております
なんかね２ちゃんのまとめに今あったんですけども
静岡県でも第四位
旧本坂トンネル
読み方当ってるか分かんない。【旧本坂トンネル】
は：やばいな…い、いくよ？えっとね、　ま：やばいんすか？ｗ来てください。どうぞ
ここは各自で☝
で、怖いのこっからですよ
なんと
ここもな☝
もう先にそういう手法があるっていう
は：そしてなんとトンネルの上には　ま：はぁい
ま：（ヒョイ）　は：（ヒョイ）お墓があるらしいです　ま：なるほどォ！
今さぁ一緒に同じ女の人見たよね
こうやって
は：結構もう近くまで来てるので、このまま行っちゃいましょう　ま：行きましょう
その前に…
ま：帰ってきた。
ま：帰ってきましたぁ～みなｓｗｗｗｗ
ま：病気ですねぇこの人
ま：笑顔で帰ってきました
ただいマックスむらいmile
あ～やだやだ！（うれしい！( *´艸｀))
もう見えちゃった…
まぁなんせ　あ～そういう深い意味はないんですよ
精力(意味深）を…こう…
心霊スポットはホント心を持ってかれるとダメなんで
は：乾杯です　ま：はい　　ｶﾝｯ
ッ!!!!
ア”ッグッフッグフ
う”う”う”う”う”う”う”う”う”っ！！
うわ、こんな味なの！？
ま：（ブルブル）　は：うわ！喉あつっ！喉あつッ！
まぁメンタル的には強いわな？
ま：間違いないっすよ？は：間違いない
早速現場まで向かっていきましょう！
（ごめんこっから手抜き）
ま：いやこれライブのｗｗ違う違うｗｗｗ　は：完全にクラ、クラブの車！
すごいけん玉好きすぎてもうコンビニ行くときとかもけん玉したいんだよけっこう
でなんかけん玉したすぎて、コンビニ、こう、入るときまでも
けん玉しながら入ったり
店内ではさすがにしないよ。しないけどこう移動する時こうやってしてて
で帰りにもこうやってけん玉してて
てか、すごい技したくなるわけよ
ま：フフッ、けん玉にすごい技ってあります？　は：いやけっこうこう、なんか、
は：腕をこう回転させ、球を回転させるような技最近してて　ナビ：ゴウケイ3ｋｍｓ…
うるさいからちょっと
すっげぇ深いこと言うじゃん
台無しだよもうｗｗ
ふぇぇぇぇぇぇ☟えへへぇぇえ☝
ま：いや長いっすよねここ？　は：長い奥が、
ま：ずーっと　は：奥が深いわ
ま：いやいや、無かった無かった　は：あったあったぁ
ま：ナカッタッテェー！は：アッタアッタァ
なかなかだねぇ～
は：＃＄％＆’（
は：え、なに？　ま：うわうわうわうわうわうわうわ
近づくにつれて口内炎が痛い
うわーすげーなー
ンダァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァヲッ!!!
ま：うわっうっうっ！
まってうわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁやっば！マジでやべぇ
ま：いやーここはきつい…
わお└(՞ةڼ◔)」
でございます…
うわぁ…
民家は無いな近くに
山奥過ぎて民家が無い
うわゆっくりって書いてある
ゆっくりしていってね！
ま：書いてありますよね。ほら　は：うーん…
おい視聴者…笑えよ
まじで超ゆっくりで行かないと行ってきｍ
ま：待って待って、なに…!?　は：はっはっ待って…！
ま：うわ待ってはじめさん、えーもうなんか…わけわかんない…
へたくそでごめんな字幕…
さてここでみなさんにひとつ
字幕を付けてる中できっとはじめんの信者とアンチ
きっとどちらもいるでしょう
はじめんはいいました。喧嘩はしないでと
最近は少し心がけているようでいいですが
やはりまだ治安が悪いようです
皆さんもはじめんの動画を見るときは
喧嘩をせず、パソコンから1km離れて視聴しましょう
僕との約束だよっ(⋈◍＞◡＜◍)。✧♡